[Music]
i'm chris benavidez deputy chief for the
san antonio police department this
critical incident video is intended to
provide you with information as the
department currently understands it
about an officer-involved shooting that
occurred in an embankment in the area of
interstate 10 and gulevada road on march
14th
i'll walk you through video relevant to
the facts of the incident as we know
them so far
content of the video may not be suitable
for all audiences viewer discretion is
advised
on march 14th at approximately 3 45 pm
officers from the department's street
crimes unit located one person that they
had been actively searching for for over
several days the suspect identified as
kevin donnell johnson
was on parole for assault of a peace
officer and was wanted on warrants for
felony possession of a firearm and
violating his parole
the uniformed officers who were in a
police vehicle with subdued markings
activated their emergency lights and
attempted to stop johnson
johnson dropped his bike and ran from
officers
the officers identified themselves as
police pursued johnson into the
embankment which is between north
elmondorf street and north hamilton
avenue
yo boy
officer spotted a gun in his right hand
as he exited the shallow water
drop your hands rub it
three officers opened fire after johnson
who was still holding the firearm rolled
forward both his body and firearm facing
toward officers on the other side of the
embankment
here's a slowed down version of the
moments leading up to the shooting
here's a view from another responding
officer's body camera the clip is
intentionally without sound
officers on the other side of the
embankment approached johnson
immediately after the shooting johnson's
firearm was found next to his body
the firearm has been forensically linked
to multiple violent crimes which
includes aggravated assault with the
deadly weapon
investigations into deadly force are
comprehensive and can take over a year
reminder this is our current
understanding of the situation and could
change as investigators gather more
information the san antonio police
department does not make any
determinations as to whether procedures
were followed until all the facts are
known
all officer-involved shootings are
forwarded to the bexar county district
attorney's office for review as of this
publication the investigation remains
ongoing
okay
[Applause]
get down boy
hands up
don't move
looking good
what do you hold people